well i'm gonna tell you a little
something about
time i had a real bad problem you know
and i didn't know how to fix it right
um the only time
me and my friends you know you know was
hanging out and stuff
and we came up on some drugs
you know like three kilos and a cocaine
and so we knew that we couldn't really
profit from it now
serving it in our own neighborhood so
what we did is we shipped it
a little bit further out of town
and while we're out here we get out
there
we got a little change in our pockets so
we buy weed
because we we you know we get a little
bit on on the pot
so we bought like a thousand dollars
worth of weed
and we got three spots going on
one in the front one in the middle and
one in the back
and so we make sure the homies have weed
and stuff while we serving and stuff
you know and things going good you know
so my boy was like uh man we've been
spending money with on these dudes right
here with
the other apartment and uh
you know let's see if they'll look out
for you know we still got some money but
we ain't got enough to wear we want to
get a little issue
so we figuring that bob's been spending
money with them
you know they would look out so we went
over there
we hollered dude say come back
my brother he was like man i think them
[ __ ] is [ __ ] man
you know [ __ ] ain't gonna give us
nothing and uh
so my brother-in-law asked me to say he
said dog when we get
when we go on the spot grab the gun and
we're gonna go back over there
and next time they got like they ain't
gonna chip us off
you know we're gonna ride their asses
and i got a real bad feeling about this
one man
i just said man i really i was trying to
tell my brother
not to even think about even going back
man
i couldn't come up with nothing right to
where i could figure out how to get some
weed
to the spot and started going over there
and uh i couldn't it didn't happen
so you know we on our way back over here
man
and dude let us in like
hold down right here i don't know how
many people's upstairs or not man
you know and uh
i draw down on the [ __ ] in the living
room
the one that that let me in i draw it
out on
and i told him man just you know just
you know i won't do nothing
i'll shoot you another but if you i had
to do what i had to do
i had to shoot you dog
and i don't
you know i don't know why i couldn't
talk my people out of this [ __ ] but man
once it's in motion man you just gotta
go with the flow you know
and bad i don't want you man you know
dude started crying and [ __ ]
you know told how many people's upstairs
man
you know he said a couple more people's
upstairs
and dude up there with his broad or
whatever
so and i'm getting ready to go upstairs
because i got the gun
i rolled upstairs dude upstairs
he got a gun i don't know he got a gun
because when i go in the room
i'm seeing him laying by the brawl but
all the time he got the gun up under
and man
you talking about having never ever
studied
how to shoot a weapon i did not know how
to shoot a weapon man
that [ __ ] ain't that gun at me man
started busting man i couldn't do
nothing to shoot back
i'm running shooting i'm running away
from it
shooting and i hit the dude man
and knocking to the floor you know
girl in the room hollering but now like
i say everything is in motion now so
you know we go in the room
scoot dude off the bed that's a gang of
money on
under the bed under the mattress and
stuff and in the closet it got like
a big old trash bag full of weed right
here
you know i mean we got pump we got a lot
of weed
i mean i ain't never seen as much weed
just personally with my own eyes
unless i saw it on tv you know yeah
so we get the we asked me how much money
we got i don't know how much money we
got we got a lot of money too man
you know i think that you know when we
came out here
out there we was gonna try and sell
these two birds of cocaine
and buy some cadillac [ __ ] there's
enough money on the bed right here
for a few cadillacs we ain't got to
think about doing that no more
so we just grabbed the money and we got
the weed going downstairs
y'all dude downstairs and uh
i told homie what you want me to do you
know
because dude upstairs is shot man and we
gotta leave
he's like uh man
he cried and [ __ ] so
my dumb man i told dude just go on the
lead get out of here
i let him leave and we left
so i go back now we scared now
because i just shot somebody ain't
nobody else did no wrong but me really
you know they access me to the crime but
i'm the one the main
my main piece to the puzzle right now
so we're in a spot we serving though
[Music]
they come in the spot with a shotgun but
you don't know that he got a shotgun
because
out here where i'm at a lot of them
dress
you know certain ways when it's cold
he got a long trench coat on like this
and
i told homie that when these
[ __ ] be coming in here like
that dog i wanna pat them down
you know you like man
man they must [ __ ] be carrying guns
and stuff dawg you know
[ __ ] ain't gonna let no [ __ ]
come in this [ __ ] spot dog
and pull out no strap on you and stuff
i'll pat you down if you don't wanna
you pat down don't hit the dough man
don't come knock on the door
and that's how i found out the [ __ ] had
the shotgun you know i patted him down
at the door i said dawg
you coming here looking too smooth with
this trench coat on man
so you got to presume the position man
he say what [ __ ] you got to hit the
wall [ __ ]
so i can pat you down make sure you
ain't carrying nothing
sure enough he had a shotgun on him and
that's how i found out
[ __ ] coming in with these these long
coats they got
they got dirty guns with them you can't
let them in and trust them
but anyway as
i did what i did so we serving
we already doing good right now got a
lot of we
we like feel like we the man
next man i know he come to police
raiding all the spots
so he did i told greenhouse
that i said dawg they hitting the spots
dog we got to go
we got to get now because i think dude
that got shot
it brought them told the police that
people who did it
still in the eat that's still in these
departments so they he going door by
door
looking and we had to leave
so me and my boy we left you know we
went out the back way and you just got
on the
train no we got on the plane he came
back here
and so far like i say it's been going
good man
you know you just think about some of
the [ __ ] you did
and you got away with it man
can i tell you if dude lived or not i
don't know
but if it was up to him he was trying to
kill me just like i just was just
i'm just busting the gun just to get up
out the room
because i when i came in the room i
thought he was in he was just
in here with his bra and then the [ __ ]
pulled out the gun and started he didn't
even
say nothing to me just started busting
and i got scared and i shot by fear
you know but when your life is on the
line you got to do something that
that you wouldn't even think you would
do in order to live
and that's what happened on my on my
behalf
i just was trying to live man
i get scared because police had me
stabbed
you know i mean the police is some real
crooked cops man you got some real
crooked moth from some cops dog that
when i tell you that you don't talk you
don't talk
if you think it's cool enough for you to
slide through and and do what you do
they got people that walk right out of
prison and blow your dog right to the
next side of the street
so if you know what you playing and you
can handle it then you do what you do
don't tell me about it because i don't
need the toughness to talk to me
share with the [ __ ] that you're gonna
meet down there in the dirt
that's what you talk to about it i know
because i've seen people that i know
on the street that's been good dude
and they walk right over there and all
the time they're being set up to
to be eliminated say man you know
[ __ ] like that you'd be surprised to
know that inside the prison walls
there's certain gangs that you got like
vanguard vgf
uh uvn cc riders these all
um things that's up on the paper
and when they read the certain papers
that you read
there's codes that you follow and you
don't break them for nothing
i don't give a [ __ ] how you talk how you
say it because when you
break them you fall ain't no come back
to talk about it
straight up it's over so if that's what
you want to play it at
play it then i'm telling you some real
live [ __ ] that
i normally wouldn't share with nobody
but there are certain things that they
do in prison same way with the mexican
mafia
when you got certain dudes inside the
prison they'll sit back here the big
shots will sit back here
and all the ponds will be up here and
the ponds will do whatever needs to be
done
if they find out you're here a head top
dog man
they'll put you in lock up and you'll
sit there
and all the little puns that you have on
this yard
he may go to lock up just to bring you a
clavo
which is drugs and stuff like that clown
is a drug
you know things that we have on the yard
um
are a wheeler a wheeler is a kite
you bring that to the head man to pass
on and then let him know what's going on
who's doing what and so on and so on if
they think that
you're doing too much on the yard they
send a [ __ ] to come get you
and they get you up off that yard
so it's a lot of things that i can share
with you that you'd be surprised to know
that it actually happened and it goes
down
if if they think that you need to be
really eliminated
they tell the police look man check this
out man um we shouldn't have some
business man we need you
kind of like step out this you know like
you didn't see nothing
and the police would turn their back and
walk to the walk through a sally porter
to look outside while you're in here
stabbing this [ __ ] to death
so when it's time to get rid of you you
going
i don't give a [ __ ] what you say you
ain't gonna get away from the train
you going now if the heart don't stop
i don't know that's probably god i ain't
challenging him
i'm just telling you some real [ __ ] when
it's time when you up against the big
man
and you up against these dudes that's
gonna eliminate your hair because
when you on when you come the street
when you come to jail dog
and they show these mother they
advertise these [ __ ] that
that's [ __ ]
or homosexuals uh uh child molesters
uh rapists and [ __ ] so when you hit that
line in there
your ass is going to be broke off i
promise you that you can laugh your ass
home away from there
what the police will do though to give
you a way out they have a bell or
something sitting right here
until you tap on this [ __ ] bill
if you don't want to hit this
[ __ ] yard man
and then tap on it you you'd be
surprised to see [ __ ] that you
thought was some big tough dude
walk through here and you say i think i
know that they say didn't hit that bill
damn look how big he is [ __ ]
don't
you can't go in this [ __ ] trying
to challenge these [ __ ] they
take they
man they take your booty man don't tell
me about you what you want what won't
happen
they put a few [ __ ] on your ass
and strip your [ __ ] ass
and take that ass and you can't do a
[ __ ] thing about
don't tell me how tough you as [ __ ] you
get a [ __ ] knife muffler ain't
worried about you getting no diet
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is nothing in the
penitentiary
they all got knives you the tough guy
bring your ass to the yard come on
out here check it out that's when they
really get funky
you know all that talking talk [ __ ] they
don't look that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
that's that's the back door y'all talk
right there the tough talk is when you
come out this front door
come out sit here face these
[ __ ] dudes that's waiting on
you man
you know so i i i've been there man
and i learned how to stop running my
mind when it's time to not run it
and when it's time to get down don't ask
questions about it just get down
you know so i i mean i had my phone used
me one time more
in the penitentiary he told me say
man i got the weed i got 300
from your peoples and and
i'm going to take care of the money i'm
going to take care of the um dope
so y'all come tell me you say asb this
[ __ ]
told me you was doing the 300
when i found out this [ __ ] did
me like i completely rowed in dog and i
swear to god
i pulled a knife on that man dog if you
ever disrespect me on this yard man
and when you get that [ __ ] dope
here dog you bring that [ __ ] you check
that [ __ ] into me now
and everything that comes up under this
[ __ ] dude right here dog
come to me [ __ ] and i mean that if i
get you side
slipping on anything or taking something
[ __ ] out the pot [ __ ] i'm gonna break
your [ __ ] ass off [ __ ] on this yard
[ __ ] and you and your homeboys can come
on and bring it right now [ __ ]
i'll [ __ ] you up first [ __ ] and that's
how i go man
when you tell a [ __ ] son [ __ ]
mean what you saying you say what you
mean
cause if you ain't ready to bag the
words of me don't stress it
don't spray it on the [ __ ]
that's that coward [ __ ] if you don't
[ __ ]
and then you get your ass off the line
[ __ ] i mean i made this [ __ ] give me
everything that
he had dawg and when this homie came up
what's up ask me [ __ ] what's up [ __ ]
he said uh i wasn't i was i was just
trying to say you know
can i just kick it with you and join in
with y'all
no [ __ ] ain't no kicking and joining in
[ __ ] but we cool though
i ain't got nothing against you dawg
it's your homeboy [ __ ]
and that you you don't side slick
nothing with none of these old fake ass
[ __ ] when you walk into your you walk
that [ __ ] strong though and
ain't nobody gonna get you no [ __ ]
and you'll make it out of there
you walk in that [ __ ] weak dog
and start accepting some of these really
poor ass [ __ ] around you
then your punk ass liable to be a [ __ ]
when you walk out of there
and i'm telling you some real [ __ ] [ __ ]
walk little [ __ ] walk together i don't
mean nothing against no fat but
i ain't into that circle we don't [ __ ]
with it like that if you cross the
bridge
they gonna break you off or even be
[ __ ] up cause you're a part of a gang
and you're supposed to stand strong
that's me i like to be strong and i like
to stand
on the front line not behind it not on
the side of it
in the front of it because i like to
lead the right way
i ain't gonna mislead you but i'm gonna
make goddamn show we make it out of here
if you wanna don't go out the other way
go [ __ ] with dude over there you want to
make it out of legit way
and keep your name good walk with me
i'm a whole gang member dog that
actually still think
i have a lot of activities inside me
a lot of functioning
that should have passed on
but by me being in jail for so long i'll
come out here
and i'm dealing with a lot of these
little young [ __ ] around that's hard
for me to even smile at a little
youngster
you know cause i don't never want a
youngster to get the wrong impression
you know i have one little [ __ ]
up down the street hollering at me
you're like what's up og
i'm like what's up he's like what's up
og
what's up i was like check this out
[ __ ] you know what the [ __ ] you talking
to homeboy
cause you keep asking me the same
[ __ ] things homeboy
and you really don't even know the [ __ ]
you talking to
i'm only asking you that because you
really need to take a timeout [ __ ]
and actually young your other homies who
i am [ __ ] before you mess your dog
mess your day off [ __ ] cause i ain't
gonna play with you
he said man i ain't like that og i said
[ __ ]
stop calling me your g [ __ ] i don't
even know the [ __ ] you [ __ ] my name is
sb
[ __ ] and i'm one of a [ __ ]
kind home boy so stop getting at me
[ __ ] before i break you off [ __ ] and
i'll beat your ass out here [ __ ]
i will beat the [ __ ] out of you [ __ ]
i'll make some goddamn show you on one
of these streets no more
you better know who the [ __ ] you talking
to then
man i ain't mean to piss og off like
that
but [ __ ] you didn't piss me off you
should have took your punk ass over
and exercise your words before you bring
your ass back up before you came over
here to talk to me
i don't even know the [ __ ] you is
homeboy
you know so some of them take it the
wrong way but you got to be tough on
these [ __ ] out here dawg
you got to be tough on these youngsters
too if you allow these [ __ ] to
slide with
with any type of slick word up on you i
guarantee you're gonna keep on doing it
but if you don't let him slide one time
you ain't gotta worry about the second
time
i don't [ __ ] around with it my tolerance
is no tolerance at all
if i didn't invite you over there don't
bring your ass over here
i don't know you don't want to know you
and i ain't asking to get to know you
so we both gonna have a good
understanding [ __ ] if you come to
shop then let me know you shop other
than that keep your ass pushing [ __ ]
don't choke up on nothing you say with
these dudes man
i promise you you'll survive out here
i'm god damn no i'm from shoulder know
that i didn't fall a few people down
and most of the [ __ ] i didn't fall out
and beat that [ __ ] ass
this one dude that kind of got a lucky
little blow on me because i thought he
was allowing me to shake me
shake his hand he stole on me we got the
fight
but i didn't get i didn't get the better
in because the [ __ ] took off on me
you know
i'm 100 man man and i guarantee you
anybody that [ __ ] with me
i ain't never crossed my st i ain't
never backstabbed him or not man i'm a
strong [ __ ] all the way
100 man and this is by nature not by
choice
i don't choose to do minds like that it
came to me and it was already
birthed in me
see this guy has some dog food some dog
food stolen
i say well first of all dog i'm not into
that
but at the same time he said but no
you know you have some you have a lot of
seniority
a lot of safety around to some of these
[ __ ] i said well check it out though
i'm gonna say it to you like this homie
i really don't give a [ __ ] about no dog
food homie
i don't i swear to god dawg you
addressing something to me that's way
beyond my lead though
now i have a homeboy that's under me
homie that you can take that [ __ ] too
and if he can't handle a dick [ __ ] i'll
come in dude but right now
dog don't address none of that [ __ ] to
me because i'm not into taking no dog
food
they got kidnapped the [ __ ] a few days
ago [ __ ] and he begged for me to
let his [ __ ] ass out the car [ __ ] so
don't tell me nothing i don't play games
dog
i don't [ __ ] with the kids [ __ ] out here
on me i'm telling you straight up
you take it to my homeboy dog and let
him hear what you got to say
and if he don't resolve a dead [ __ ]
then you come to me [ __ ] but don't come
to me first oh
boy cause i don't [ __ ] with dogs or food
like that
that ain't my that ain't my spiel homie
now at the same time he says me i don't
mean no disrespect to you
i didn't take it under disrespect [ __ ]
i just told you to don't call at me
about somebody else's dog food [ __ ]
i don't walk down the street they go
watching if a [ __ ] boosted some damn
dog food [ __ ]
so he like all right here's me man i
apologize
don't apologize to me because we have no
bad understanding
i just want you to know you take it to
the [ __ ] that's up under me
before you bring it to me i'm older i'm
the top dog [ __ ] i'm the real i'm the
real mccoy the homie
down there is the dudes that's still
developing so check them out first
and they'll let me know if they can't
handle it and i'll come to you
till then though we ain't got nothing
else to say
i did a movie
you